When I think about being on stage
and performing,
first thing that comes to my mind is...
intensity.
When Run was being Run,
Darryl was being Darryl,
and Jay was being Jay,
it was heaven.
It was Nirvana.
When we get on stage
we do what we gotta do.
Rock the house.
Party people.
Your dreams have now been fulfilled.
Hollis, Queens.
Hold up.
Let’s back up.
My reason for getting into rap
was the streets.
Everybody in the neighborhood
started getting two turntables and a mixer.
At this point, me and D,
we were dreaming about
making our own stuff.
Grab your rhyme book.
We’re going to the studio
to make a record.
♪ Here we go ♪
That was the moment I knew
hip-hop was gonna be huge.
They brought more people to the genre.
♪ Tricky Tricky Tricky Tricky ♪
All this from two turntables
and a microphone.
Now that it’s a hit
you gotta go perform it in front of people.
We exploded out of nowhere.
It was so big it overtook us.
What defines greatness
is how you react
when things aren’t going great.
D!
Open the door!
I wasn’t dealing with
the feelings and the emotions
that I was going through.
I was just ready to give up.
After that, all hell broke loose.
Run DMC is officially retired.
It made him go...
This is who we are.
And we ain’t from The Bronx.
And we ain’t from Brooklyn.
We from Queens!
They made something
that no one ever made before.
They the reason hip-hop is as
big as it is right now.
I did not know until the last second
that I was about to go do something
so big and so historic.
They changed the sound of music,
the audience for rap music.
When you saw me, Run, and Jay,
you didn’t see celebrity.
You saw yourself.
You get in front of the world...
and you let people know who you are.